even look at mark zuckerberg i mean his
genius was not his his technical
aptitude the the predecessor to facebook
i mean i was at harvard with him at the
same time maybe i was a year ahead of me
back that was hot or not
you know this or this
sort of taking these native base human
instincts and just picking at them and
exploiting them
you know
does that mean that we should we should
regulate the companies and prevent them
from doing that no no you're getting it
all wrong
we need to revive the very institutions
at the level of the family at the level
of the nation at the level of the
community at the level of even our
religious institutions to fill that void
of meaning and purpose and identity
that then prepares us for a society
where
in free market capitalism we don't need
to apologize for the fact that some guy
ends up with more green pieces of paper
than the other
who cares if we fetishize those green
pieces of paper what the thing that
really matters is that we have civic
equality as citizens that we're grounded
in the forms of identity that really
matter and that's where i want to see
the conservative movement do better than
stepping up to fill that void
yeah it's interesting you're making a
distinction that i try to bring up all
the time that it's that it's perceived
depression not necessarily even real
oppression
it's something that's made up in their
mind so where do you think big tech fits
in this you know when we hear things
like well okay all of this gender stuff
and all of this woke stuff it's pushed
on all of kids in america through tick
tock but it's banned in china do you
think that that there might be a
connection there yeah or even the china
the parent company that owns tick tock
in china actually uses it to like
educate kids on math and science and
reading which is different than the way
we're educating people here so so look i
mean
mostly when i'm talking about you know
big tech or the term big tech i'm
usually talking about the censorship uh
debate which you know
views on but that's not what i'm going
to talk about here
this is a different issue and i think
that
i think it's an important one where
look one of the things i often say uh
not to get too philosophical here for
but will just for a second is that
virtue is not a product of capitalism
okay virtue is a precondition
for capitalism to do its work and what i
mean by that is that
look i i often a simple way of saying
that is capitalism would be the perfect
system for organizing a society's
affairs
if our wants actually matched our needs
and to the extent that there's anything
wrong wrong with it with with negative
externalities with capitalism it can
explain it can be explained entirely i
believe by the daylight between our
wants and needs and i think part of what
the stakeholder capitalism movement gets
wrong
is that it demands of these capitalist
actors
the need to cultivate virtue that should
have been cultivated through
institutions that predate capitalism
capital into society the family is
perhaps
yeah right religion whatever it is you
know
where you pray national identity
patriotism at the level of the community
at the level of family absolutely
so so so why do we see this play out as
it relates to tech companies and where
does the debate even get confused even
by conservatives over the last year for
example was when i saw this story break
out by you know the wall street journal
doing reporting that um you know
facebook knew that the young teen girls
who were using instagram
had body image and security issues that
were fueled and made worse by instagram
and they didn't do anything about it
and
by the way they knew that they were
making anger management issues amongst
their angry users even worse but didn't
do anything about it and so you know
conservative media called me to talk
about
that issue because i had been a long
critic of censorship by big tech and so
okay let's hit them hard they knew and
they didn't do anything about it
actually my view was actually no no
you're getting this all wrong actually
we should not as a society want mark
zuckerberg or jack dorsey to be our
priests and rabbis
to virtue in fact we should want a
society that cultivates the kind of
self-confidence among young teen girls
that don't leave them vulnerable
to the insecurities that
these algorithms are designed to prey on
and i think that we miss the fact that
we can cultivate that sense of psychic
fortitude and virtue in the offline
world
so that these
professionally created algorithms aren't
so well equipped to pick at and prey on
those insecurities by knowing what you
click on versus what you don't click on
and use that to create a window to your
soul that sees your soul with greater
clarity than you see yourself
that's just that's just the the
antecedent condition of the divergence
of your want and need that deficit of
virtue that allowed the modern demonic
algorithmic version algorithm empowered
version of modern capitalism and and
technology the industry part of it to
prey on those insecurities it's kind of
like the equivalent of a teen girl in
the 1990s
you know a virginia slim manufacturer
selling cigarettes to that teen girl who
had body image and security issues back
then it's the same thing all over again
when the thing we need to be addressing
is the generational insecurity in the
first place and cultivating that psychic
fortitude that actually allows
capitalism to then do its work to sell
us the goods and services we want more
effectively when we already have a
deep-seated self-confidence and
understanding of who we are as people
that predate cap our identity as
capitalists and so this is one of the
solutions i talk about in the book is
you know one of the places i want to see
the conservative movement do better
is to provide an
affirmative answer to those questions
about identity about national identity
about individual identity and to talk
not just about
the revival of freedom through system or
system of free market capitalism or i'm
one of the greatest champions for
exactly that model
but also to talk about a revival of
let's say civic identity our identity as
citizens and the psychic fortitude that
we require as citizens and the civic
duty that comes in our capacity as a
citizen from our identity as just a
capitalist who's participant in that
economy and so what did big tech do they
called that bluff
this modern social media called the
bluff
of a generation that didn't know what
they actually wanted and then prayed on
those psychic insecurities to build
multi-trillion dollar companies that
were not tech companies they were
psychologically they were
psychologically shrewd companies that
understood that they could understand
you better with their algorithms than
you could understand yourself and maybe
if you understood yourself even more
effectively that might have actually
prevented modern social media from
having the toxic effects that it's since
had revec am i a crazy conspiracy
theorist or is it possible that for all
those years that buzzfeed had everyone
clicking on those nonsensical polls of
what do they like better this or that
that perhaps that had a little something
buzzfeed and many of these other sites
but buzzfeed which is now completely
collapsed was like the prime purveyor of
all of us clicking all these things and
they would as you sort of alluded to
there ultimately they would know what we
actually want more than we can even
understand that's not a conspiracy
that's a reality i mean look even look
at mark zuckerberg i mean his genius was
not his his technical aptitude the the
predecessor to facebook i mean i was at
harvard with him at the same time maybe
he was a year ahead of me back that was
hot or not
you know this or this so sort of taking
these native bass human instincts and
just picking at them and exploiting them
you know
does that mean that we should we should
regulate the companies and prevent them
from doing that no no you're getting it
all wrong
we need to revive the very institutions
at the level of the family at the level
of the nation at the level of the
community at the level of even our
religious institutions to fill that void
of meaning and purpose and identity
that then prepares us for a society
where
in free market capitalism we don't need
to apologize for the fact that some guy
ends up with more green pieces of paper
than the other who cares if we fetishize
those green pieces of paper what the
thing that really matters is that we
have civic equality as citizens that
we're grounded in the forms of identity
that really matter
and that's where i want to see the
conservative movement do better in
stepping up to fill that void in a way
that it's completely abdicated any
interest in actually taking on that's
part of what motivated me to say that
you know i just wasn't done with just
woke inc you know nation of victims was
about taking a crack i'm not saying i
have all the answers but taking a crack
at
what fills that void of identity what
does it mean to be an american in the
year
2022 if we don't have a good answer to
that question maybe we as a movement
need to be stepping up detroit and
answer that question or else you're
going to have the same black that same
poison continuing to fill that black
hole of a vacuum of identity rather than
just taking a jackhammer to sort of weed
out that poison one at a time maybe you
try a different strategy of diluting the
poison to irrelevance by filling it with
a new rich vision for what that identity
could be that dilutes the poison to
irrelevance if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell